-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's great to hear.
Let's get to the news.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
is facing criticism
after she gave a speech
yesterday
thanking George Floyd for,
quote, "sacrificing your lif
for justice."
Wow, who'd have thought we'd
prefer her moment of silence
That's right,
Nancy Pelosi gave a speech
thanking George Floyd for,
quote,
"sacrificing your life
for justice."
You know, if you're
an 81-year-old white perso
giving a speech about race
you can just follow
this simple rule --
don't.
After former Minneapolis
Police Officer Derek Chauvin
was found guilty yesterday
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
claimed the jury was intimidated
into the guilty verdict
by the protests and
the Black Lives Matter movement,
which is frustrating for Carlson
because he put a lot of work
into intimidating that jury.
Former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie
is reportedly considering a ru
for President in 2024.
He thinks he might do well
in the polls
as long as "none of the above"
doesn't run again.
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
celebrated the launch
of his new social media
platform, Frank, this week
by holding a 48-hour
live-stream marathon.
What? How is anybody supposed to
stay awake for 48 --
Oh, right. MyPillow.
Officials
in Burlington, Vermont,
recently banned the use
of gas-powered leaf blower
due to noise complaints.
Said one resident, "Finally,
for the first time in my life,
I could speak
with my normal voice."
Florida Governor Ron DeSanti
recently signed into law
what he calls the, quote,
"strongest anti-rioting,
pro-law enforcement measur
in the country."
So maybe now, your grandparent
will think twice
before butting in line
for the early-bird special
According to a recent report
the U.K.'s fossil fuel industr
may achieve
net zero carbon emissions
before it achieves
gender equality.
Either way, 2090 is shaping up
to be a really exciting year
Netflix announced yesterda
that it will spend $17 billion
on content for 2021.
"Oh! Oh, honey, no.
We're --
We're going outside now."
Finally, Apple
yesterday announced
a new purple-colored iPhone.
So, is that new enough for you
Happy?
Are you greedy vultures read
to get an entirely new
but practically identical phon
a year after
you bought your last one?
'Cause these guys can't
keep reinventing
the mother-loving wheel.
They added the third lens,
but you hated the third lens
Then they gave you
a redheaded emoji,
but then you all suddenly
hated redheads.
Fine. Then guess what.
You get a purple phone now
Boom. That's the new
groundbreaking phone.
So just give them $1,000,
come pick up your dumb
purple mean machines,
and go back to
your pathetic little lives
That was the actual
press release.
And that was a monologue.